a six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go to
the four seven zero area code caller
from four seven zero go ahead
hey there David can you hear me just
barely speak up as much as you can't
let's turn them up as much as we can
alrighty my name is Sam I'm from Georgia
and I've been reading a lot recently
about Donald Trump and the Republican
Party trying to push a lot of the
immigration issue and now trying to push
the gun debate on to ms-13 as a way to
try to put a criminal face on what seems
to be the entire span of community right
so what I'm curious about is whether
ms-13 is really as much of a national
threat as the Republican Party tries to
make it sound like it is yes so Sampson
talking about what gang that originated
it's a pretty originated in the
California prison system ms-13 and I
think it's made up correct me if I'm
wrong Sam predominantly of individuals
from a particular South American country
and I don't remember what or is it El
Salvador now I wouldn't be able to tell
you okay yeah let's assume it's El
Salvador yeah I mean listen anyone who
says that we just shouldn't worry about
ms-13 is obviously wrong like we should
worry about ms-13 but the idea that
ms-13 is such a danger that our policy
on immigration or incarceration or
deportation or whatever needs to be
based around ms-13 it's an exaggeration
and so I think that any tragedy any
violence at the hands of ms-13 is
absolutely horrific and what I'm saying
doesn't devalue any individual instances
of that but we're talking about a tiny
fraction of the broader issues that are
major major issues that we're talking
about it's important not to get lulled
into thinking of that as the problem all
right perfect
thanks very much for answering my
question all right Sam very much
appreciated and on
note we will wrap up we've got a great
bonus show for you today and all sorts
of other great stuff thanks to everybody
who called in sorry to all the people we
didn't get to but we will take phone
calls again